Tổ thông viên thuộc đảng giống chủ, ông viên Clinton ngay hôm 12 đã có phía nhiều trần kiến trước
quy bàn giọng xác hà viện về mối quan hệ với nhà tại Việt quà của hỗ đồng thời là
tên tội phạm tình giục Jeffrey Astane tại phía nếu trần ok tần hàng định không thể điều gì
đang nghi và không biết về khang vì phạm tội của Astane vì kêu tổng thống cho biết
tần bay chính mấy bài riêng của Astane vào đầu những năm 2020 sau phía dời nhìn
giờ chùi yêu hất táo lên qua đến hoàn động của quý từ thệm Clinton, nhưng nói sẽ không
bệnh nhiều biết về cả vụ quốc buồn bàn tình giục Jeffrey thánh nghiên và sẽ bao gáo nếu phía xa phạm,
ông nhìn mạnh đã chấm rất liên hệ với Astane sau khi người này bị két án năm
hành hình y let án, chùi tịch quy bàn James Comer, Mô ta phía nếu trần lớn táo,
một số nghĩa xí cộng hoa cho rằng có điểm chưa nhất quán trong lời khai trong khi các nghĩa xí dẫn
chủ kêu gọi chíu tập tổng thống đúng đúng không? Trong để bảo đam tình tòa diện
đã chíu của quý đều tra, chíu đó vô ông Clinton là kiểu march yưởng Hillary Clinton nói,
không nhớ tình gặp Astane, một tương phà Mỹ cho biết rằng giả xóa hủ xíu lìm quan,
giới trực Mỹ cho biết việc một cá nhân xó hiện trong khủ xíu Astane không đúng nghĩa của hành vi phạm tôi.